here in America's breadbasket the
coronavirus has yet to descend in force
on the nation's farms but John Keith nah
knows it's coming and the timing could
hardly be worse some people are gonna
get sick the numbers are out there the
history now of this virus is we're not
going to avoid it like most farmers
Keith nur who raises corn soybean and
chickens is already socially isolated
but the average u.s. farmer is fifty
eight and a half years old putting them
in the high-risk group for the global
pandemic that is yet to reach much of
rural America a lot of younger farmers
aren't worried about it all I'm of this
mindset that I'm probably not gonna
avoid it I'm gonna get it and I'd rather
get it now in the past year American
farms have endured damaging floods a
trade war with China and now a virus
that threatens their workers and their
ability to transport food to market if
we shrink the labor pool this year
that's going to be terrible how the
emphasis is on the supply chain and my
biggest fear is the transportation
industry we constantly have a shortage
of truck drivers so truck drivers need
to avoid this virus on Chicago's
mercantile exchange and throughout the
Midwestern farm belt agricultural income
fell nearly 10 percent compared with
last year and that was before the virus
with socks riding a roller coaster on
Wall Street and coronavirus shuttering
one business after another farm
economists say tighten belts could mean
more frugal shoppers then there's the
worry about getting livestock to market
meatpacking plants are labor-intensive
that would be the biggest uh problem
would be if these if even half the
processing plants let's say had to shut
down even temporarily it's gonna drive
down price for a while because you're
gonna have a backing up in the supply
chain
John Keith nurse says farms can get
through the short-term but the longer
the crisis lasts the more strained
America's food supply will be if this
becomes a long too long pandemic there's
gonna be a lot of people relying on US
farmers until then Keith nur and farmers
like him are doing their best to stay
isolated and in good health john Hendren
al-jazeera Chicago